today on the Matt wall show our big
rally in Nashville was a major success
even in spite of the satanic leftist
zombies who showed up to try and derail
the event we'll recap it all for you
today also Joe Biden invites Tick-Tock
trans influencer Dylan Mulvaney to the
White House where Biden claims among
other things that states do not have the
right to protect children from
mutilation and the University of
Wisconsin-Madison denounces my event
tonight despite having approved my event
weeks ago plus the by Administration
sends troops to Ukraine even though we
were told that there would be no boots
on the ground there and our daily
cancellation a man exposes himself on
live television but it's okay even
heroic and beautiful we're told because
he identifies as a woman all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
Wade has been overturned and this battle
is now finally leaving DC and going to
the Grassroots no group in America is
better positioned than 40 Days for life
to handle this with about 1 million
volunteers and 1 000 cities 40 Days for
life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities they have a larger
presence in blue states with California
being their largest state some abortion
facility directors say these vigils can
cause the no the uh the abortion no-show
rate to go as high as 75 percent which
of course is detrimental to their
abortion business to say the least these
law-abiding vigils have closed many
abortion businesses in America nearly
half of those closed abortion facilities
were in Liberal cities where abortion
will remain legal including um uh you
know places like San Francisco Chicago
and Seattle places where they're needed
the most 40 Days for life is effectively
changing hearts and Minds in the
Grassroots to end abortion you can check
out their locations podcasts and free
magazine at 40daysforlife.com and you
know uh if you think that this fight is
over and we can all just move on with
our lives
because of Roe v Wade being overturned
you were sorely mistaken the fight is
more important now than ever so for more
information go to 40 Days for life
um.com again that's 40daysforlife.com
well when it comes to activism
conservatives uh operate at a
considerable disadvantage I think the
left monopolizes many areas of the
culture perhaps none more than this this
field of activism they have structures
in place that allow them to organize
their activist activities
quickly and effectively they have armies
of paid Astro turfed protesters ready to
be mobilized at a moment's notice they
have of course the entire corporate
media in their pocket always there to
promote their efforts Drive attendance
and then give their events glowing news
coverage after the fact but their
greatest Advantage which is perhaps a
consequence of everything I just listed
is that leftists in general are more
prone to get involved in activism in the
first place it comes to it comes to them
more naturally I guess you could say
conservatives are far more reluctant to
get involved in these sorts of things
either because they don't see the
Practical benefit of it or because
they're worried about the blowback or
because the whole idea is just too weird
and foreign to them or some combination
of these the end result is that activism
is a weapon an extremely effective
weapon wielded almost exclusively by one
side of the ideological divide the major
exception is the pro-life movement which
does manage to hold a massive barge once
a year but outside of that activism on
the right tends usually to be a small
um sort of disjointed affair
I'm well acquainted with these
challenges having been involved in
right-wing activism over the years and
it was uh front of Mind a few weeks ago
when we announced our plans to hold a
rally in Nashville
calling for an end to child gender
transitions otherwise uh referred to
more appropriately as child mutilation
it's a considerable risk to put together
an event like this in the cultural
context just described
the most disastrous and embarrassing
possible outcome is that only a couple
hundred people show up and and then the
problem is that you end up making a
statement very much contrary to the one
you set out to make you wanted to show
that lots of people support this idea
but then only a few people are there and
it doesn't really work out many
conservative rallies and margins have
suffered such a fate
and not necessarily because there aren't
many people who agree with whatever
they're rallying around but just because
of the reasons I already listed they
that they are just aren't showing up
so it's a risk but it was a risk worth
taking and I'm happy to report now in
hindsight that uh the risk did pay off
in a big way for us so we held our rally
outside the capitol here in Nashville on
Friday according to the official
estimates from the local police we ended
up with a crowd of around 3 000 people
now I can tell you that I was hoping for
at least one thousand I would have been
very happy with 1500 we doubled that
threshold in spite of the built-in
obstacles it was an enormously
successful event made all the better by
the compelling speakers we had on hand
Dr Colin Wright Tulsi gabbard Chloe Cole
Scott Nugent uh Robbie and Landon
Starbucks Senator Marshall Blackburn
among plenty of others all delivering
powerful defenses of Truth and Powerful
defenses of our children so we had we
had two primary goals for this rally one
was to further uh Inspire our state
lawmakers to follow through
legislatively and to legally ban child
mutilation in our state having spoken to
a number of them backstage at the rally
I can report that um
well they were officially inspired and
very impressed so that part
worked out I'm confident that the law
will get passed very quickly in this
state once the legislature is back in
session which will happen in a few weeks
the other goal was to spark a movement
that would extend beyond Tennessee and
inspire people across the country to
stand up against this madness and when I
say stand up against it I mean to take
to the streets to make themselves
visible to show up physically
not just on the internet
and I think we were successful in that
regard too but of course only time would
really tell the full story there are
certainly more needs to be done to turn
this into a national movement you can't
accomplish that with one rally of course
and I intend to stay very much involved
in that effort as we go across the
nation I don't think that I don't think
of myself as someone that was like Born
to Be an activist there's some people
who seem that way I don't see myself
that way it's not something that ever I
ever felt myself especially
suited for but someone has to help lead
this charge and at least for now
it seems that job has fallen to me so be
it
wasn't all sunshine and Roses though we
knew the left would do their best to
sabotage and derail our efforts and so
they did
leftist counter protesters were there on
Friday some of them certainly of the
paid variety some were armed antifa
members in tactical gear so they were
there and the rest were just this kind
of ragtag bunch of emotionally disturbed
Freaks and losers before it started one
counter protester with a hairstyle model
modeled I think after Heath Ledger's
Joker
explained that the guy who organized the
rally is a terrorist listen
[Music]
propaganda
and you support anything he says you are
indoctrinating everyone you know into
being a Nazi Matt Walsh is a sarcastic
terrorists
I just have to say one thing is that uh
if you want to go with the green hair
you you could you could do that as a
free country but the only problem is
that if you have green hair you have
officially precluded yourself
from ever calling someone else a lunatic
it just doesn't work you can't accuse
someone of lunacy while having green
hair
now he has no idea what the term
stochastic terrorist means because it
doesn't mean anything
but he's sure you know that I am one
whatever it means and that guy say
whatever else you want about him he was
actually rather reasonable and
respectful compared to the rest of the
graduates of the mutant Academy who
showed up witness for example this white
guy
screaming at another white person that
she is a white cracker who will burn in
hell
nobody knows who you are nobody cares
and you will die alone you'll die alone
and you will burn in hell
nobody knows who you are you'll die
alone
they really it's like you when you see
them screaming before you see the rest
of the cards you would think that they
were screaming at a mirror because the
everything they're saying perfectly
nobody knows who you are you will die
alone I could not think of a better uh
way to describe the person you just saw
in that video
and we see another of the advantages
actually that the left has in this world
this world of activism and you saw it
there in that video you know because you
had the guy screaming and then the woman
who was standing there
um the thing for the left is that so
many of them are sick deranged
freakazoids while the people who show up
on the other side are just normal human
beings they're tax paying citizens with
jobs and children
and many of them simply aren't prepared
to be confronted by green-haired
schizophrenics with bullhorns you saw
that woman she's like I said normal
woman
now in that case she was she although
she was being verbally harassed and and
uh and verbally assaulted she handles it
quite well she handles it like a pro but
in general this is you know there are
lots of people who are just like they
see something like this like I'm too
normal to be a part of this crowd as
time went on however the counter
protesters they didn't bother to
articulate words anymore instead they
just started screeching like brain
damaged lizards listen
hmm
it makes a compelling argument you have
to admit but not as compelling as this
crew
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
men this is what happens if you don't
stay at home and raise your kids right
there that's that's what happens you
want your kids to turn into that you
want to be disgraced and ashamed for the
rest of your life
because that's what your children turned
into
Now They carried on with this routine
during the event uh trying to drown out
the speakers and prevent us from being
heard at you know at most rallies and
marches especially if it's for a leftist
cause counter protesters have to stand
off around the perimeter so that the
group that obtained the permit for the
space can hold their event that's part
of the whole point of like getting a
permit which we did but for our rally
for whatever reason the city allowed the
leftist trolls to come right into the
middle of the crowd uh with bullhorns
and sirens and vulgar chants and all the
rest of it
they continued even when they continue
for the entire event even when uh for
example Chloe Cole got up to speed
because she's an 18 year old
d-transitioner
who came to share her own experiences
her own rather horrifying experiences
with gender transition she's a victim of
medical malpractice and came to talk
about that
the leftist trolls in the crowd
responded by chanting Fu fascists the
whole time she was speaking to a
traumatized 18 year old girl
now Chloe continued on uh I think
heroically unfazed none of our speakers
were rattled or flustered by the
commotion and we all managed to be heard
above the Demonic shrieking in fact as I
said from the stage on Friday
in the end I have to be grateful that
the disgusting Health spawns did show up
because it provided exactly the kind of
contrast
that I want people to see on one hand
you have normal decent Americans of all
ages and demographics
speaking out against one of the great
atrocities of our time
and on the other hand you have a bunch
of screeching goblins who have no
argument to present no point to make and
are only interested in silencing The
Other Side by whatever means necessary
so it's just it's up to each member of
the public to decide whose side they
want to be on so you see that footage
you decide who who do you want to line
up with
of course it is after the event
um that the leftist vultures really get
to work the freaks go home to their
parents houses and the media takes over
um the media's first priority and
favored strategy for something like this
is to just ignore any conservative March
or rally if they can this is what they
do with the March for Life 500 000
people out there they just pretend it
didn't exist and that's what they prefer
to Simply pretend
that it never happened and let its
memory quickly fade away but in our case
the event was big and loud and
impressive enough that ignoring it was
not an option so they scrambled to plan
B which is to blatantly lie and
mischaracterize the tennesseans article
on the rally is representative I think
listen to this paragraph This is what's
in the article quote the so-called rally
to end child mutilation an event
organized by the conservative daily wire
blog this event drew a Motley crowd of
about 1500 anti-transgender rights
activists pro-transgender rights
activists proud boys people protesting
circumcision and a variety of other
right and left-leaning political
activists
okay so they call the daily wire a Blog
um they cut our crowd size in half and
then they pretend that the crowd was
essentially an equal assortment of
people on both the right and left
and truth of course we outnumbered the
counter protesters by probably 20 to 1.
if not more than that
there are probably dozens of media
reports about the rally and nearly all
of them use these same tactics another
favorite strategy is this one by an AP
reporter she tweeted she tweeted this
along with a video she says very bizarre
scene here in Nashville today Matt Walsh
Tulsi gabbard Senator Blackburn and
other Republicans are scheduled to hold
a rally calling to ban gender affirming
care for minors trans right supporters
are in the crowd it appears country
music is blaring to drown them out she
follows that with this odd claim she
says there's an argument to be made that
this rally is really just to praise Matt
Walsh
yeah I hold a held a rally the praise
Matt Walsh rally no that's that's not
dissonant that's uh we're doing that in
two months
there's also you know so that's there's
an argument to be made for that she says
there's also an argument to be made that
that you know you are a political
propagandist masquerading as a
journalist Kimberly
and the difference is that there's
evidence to support that argument
but the main point is that Kimberly made
sure to tweet footage of the crowd taken
before the event started there's a lot
of this on the left they showed up like
an hour hour and a half early started
taking pictures of the crowd an hour
before it even started and they said
look at this it's hardly anyone here
uh at a time when you know a half or
two-thirds of the attendees hadn't
showed up yet and then as soon as
everybody was there the event was
happening you noticed that they stopped
tweeting pictures of the crowd it's
interesting how that works Kimberly
eventually published an article for the
AP claiming of course that hundreds of
people were there rather than thousands
who were actually there but she also
it's the interesting thing is that in
the article she only mentions my name
once as an aside while listing the
speaker she goes through the whole
argument at the very end she says and
there are other speakers there too
including Matt Walsh and yada yada
but on Twitter she was convinced that
the entire rally was about me
which isn't
but you know why should the propagandist
pick one lie or the other there's no
reason to you don't have to settle on
one when you can have them all that's
the benefit of being a liar I suppose
it's only if you're if you care about
the truth that you have to worry about
things like consistency but you know
lies you can tell any lie you want
all in all
between the media's lies and the left's
attempts to sabotage us
one message comes through loud and clear
and the message is that we are winning
okay
they're throwing everything they can
against the wall because we are
succeeding
we have all the momentum right now and
they know it
and they're afraid
and they should be
now
they still Harbor delusions that these
kinds of tactics will um
scare us away
and and the thing is maybe they have
reason to think that because in the past
they have been able to intimidate
conservatives by screaming in their face
lying about them in the media on and on
but not this time
because we aren't those kinds of
conservatives
that was a different era of conservatism
weren't a new era now this is a new
breed you're dealing with guys
and we're not going away
this is just the beginning
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
Court decision to overturn Roe is a huge
albeit long overdue step in the right
direction but there's still a long way
to go to rid our country of abortion
many companies are bowing to the woke
mob by donating to pro-choice causes and
candidates or even reimbursing their
employees travel expenses so that if
they live and work in a pro-life State
they can travel to a pro-abortion state
get an abortion be back at work on them
on Monday well what if I told you that
if you're currently on a phone plan with
one of the major carriers you might be
supporting these companies and their
pro-abortion agendas with your monthly
phone bill don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe and switch to Charity mobile
instead Charity mobile is a pro-life
pro-family cell phone company that sends
five percent of your monthly plan price
to the pro-life charity of your choice
you don't have to compromise on values
or good phone service Charity mobile
offers the latest 5G phones no device or
service contracts great Nationwide
coverage
and a live customer service base right
here in the U.S the fight for the right
to life continues and pro-life causes
needs your support you can help by
simply switching your phone service to
Charity mobile today you can call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code Walsh to redeem a free cell phone
at charitymobile.com mention code Walsh
um I also wanted to mention this as we
so we had the rally on Friday uh but the
what is a woman College Tour continues
and I am right now because I'm in
another random hotel room is that I'm in
uh Madison Wisconsin I'm going to
University of Wisconsin-Madison tonight
to screen the film do a q a and all that
um and so uh what that means is that of
course there are there are anti and me
protests here as well
um this one's a little different though
because the university university itself
has officially joined in
so this was um
tweeted by the uh the yat below the yaf
chapter here on campus
and here's what they tweeted campus
unrest about Matt Walsh is ramping up
instead of calming emotions over an
event they both approved and are
providing support for UW Madison chooses
to vilify our speaker on social media
and Pander to the Mob predictably
inconsistent and outright shameful
and then they have uh screenshots of a
statement put out by University of
Wisconsin-Madison put out on Instagram
and here's what their statement said
this is again from the University itself
this is their official statement
we are aware that a speaker is coming to
campus on Monday whose viewpoints We
Believe are harmful towards our trans
community
we feel the impact this is having on our
campus and we wanted to reach out
no okay first of all as the Wisconsin
yaf chapter points out they're not just
aware that a speaker is coming they
approve the event yaf has been working
with them for weeks to to organize this
event make sure we have everything we
need Logistics security and all that
although now I'm starting to wonder how
much security support we're actually
going to get from them but they continue
on
over the past several weeks many of you
have rallied around our students and one
another to offer support and community
we affirm include and celebrate people
across the spectrum of identities
Expressions experiences and perspectives
every day and especially in times like
this this is who we are as a community
oh they affirm and celebrate people
across the spectrum of perspectives
except my perspective
which is harmful and they feel they have
to apologize for it
so they they affirm the whole spectrum
of perspectives as long as it's this one
particular perspective
that's what I mean by the Spectrum that
we affirm the entire spectrum of radical
of of far-left opinions
we affirm and celebrate the entire
spectrum of everything the far left says
that's what they really mean
they continue to the trans members of
our UW-Madison Community we see you and
we value you we will continue to do our
part to make this campus more welcoming
and inclusive regardless of what
speakers May
of what speakers May counter this value
what
this is a university they can't even
write in coherent sentences we will con
okay I'm trying to make sense of this
we will continue to do our part to make
this campus more welcoming and inclusive
regardless of what speakers May counter
this value
of the speakers who counter this
so I'm I am countering the value of
trans people by speaking
what does that mean what are you trying
what does that even mean
how does it how can you counter
somebody's value
much less by speaking
we see you we value you we are with you
and then it is signed by Christina
olstadters the dean of students and she
provides her pronouns and then Gabe
javiar who's the vice Chancellor of
student affairs
um and also provides his pronouns too
so there you go now this is you might
think well it doesn't it's like whatever
Universe it does before you show up not
really actually this is this is uh
I think I say it's unprecedented I don't
know about that but it's it's actually
unusual for the University to officially
apologize for and denounce speakers
before they even show up
and um it does certainly make you wonder
what kind of as I said what kind of
assistance they're really going to be
offering when uh when it comes down to
it meanwhile the the leftist protesters
on campus
have been making their uh opinions known
here by spraying graffiti all over the
campus now this usually again you go to
campuses a lot of times they'll use
chalk and they'll write you know Matt
Walsh is a big meanie or whatever in
shock but in this case they're actually
spray paint this is this is graffiti and
so they've um this is one of the
reporters with the student newspaper
says UW Madison's alumni Park was
vandalized with messages supporting the
transmitter just hours before
conservative commentator Matt Walsh is
scheduled to appear it says fuw and yeah
Matt Walsh equals Nazi
stop letting not see
you know and then it's cut off stop
letting Nazi stop letting Nazis do what
what aren't Nazis supposed to do I need
to know the rest of the message and then
um
also
in in huge letters right across the
front of the building his spray painted
trans women are women F Matt Walsh and
yaff
I could not ask for better
advertisements for this event so I do
appreciate that
um and there's been more vandalism too
it just a couple of the quick ones first
of all
once again
if there's anybody on the left on campus
who uh feels that feels this way and
thinks trans women are women and that
I'm a Nazi and I'm harmful and I'm
bigoted and all this kind of stuff
well all you have to do is come to the
event
and if you can get behind a microphone
at the Q a
and defend the proposition that trans
women are women if you can successfully
defend it
thereby debunking my entire position
then you will have really silence me
because you know what's going to happen
then if you could do that
I I again here's what I would do here's
my here's my pledge if you can
successfully defend the proposition of
trans women are women
um right to my face I will
immediately retire from public life
disgraced and ashamed
on the spot I'll just walk away from the
microphone and say I'm done and I'll
apologize
if you if if you can successfully defend
that trans woman or women
if you can
um or you can huddle outside and scream
and spray paint and all that so and the
second point is that you know we hear
about words being incitement and
stochastic terrorism and all the rest of
it I could very reasonably make the case
that the University of Wisconsin-Madison
is actually trying to incite violence
against me
by saying ahead of time that I am
harmful to the community by saying that
ahead of time when they know
that there's all these crazy leftists
there and they're spray painting they're
already committing crimes
in the lead up to me showing up
I could very easily make the case that
this is an example of inciting violence
you've got these deranged lunatics and
you tell them that yeah this guy's
harmful to you he's dangerous
if one of them tries to act on that then
who's to blame for that
not that I'm at all worried I'll still
be there no question about it all right
so Biden met in the white house with a
bunch of tick tock stars or whoever
these people are and there were a few
concerning moments the most glaring of
which was in exchange with a guy that
you'll unfortunately recognize uh Dylan
Mulvaney once again the man who has
risen quickly to prominence on the
strength of his degrading cartoonish
impression of a woman and I mean just
just follow the trajectory of this dude
okay he he's just a dude no one's heard
of
and then he decides one day he wants to
be a woman and starts doing his uh
starts doing his you know Woman face
um his menstrual show impression of a
woman
and then immediately he's trying he's
trending on Tick Tock he's got a massive
social media following corporate brands
are uh lining up to give him money and
then the White House contacts him and
invites him to come speak to the
president of the United States this is
the privilege you get if you're a man
who identifies as a woman this is how
you get you get to you get to uh
you go right to the front of the line in
front of all these other if if
Joe Biden wanted to invite a woman to
the White House to talk about women's
issues there are millions of them to
choose from
but no he decided to take this man and
invite him instead so
uh invited to the White House and it led
to
um a couple of change we'll start with
this brief Exchange
about the efforts in some states like
the one that I live in to ban sex change
surgeries for kids uh gender mutilation
for kids and here's what Biden had to
say about that do you think States
should have a right to ban gender
affirming health care I don't think any
state or anybody should have the right
to do that
as a moral question as legal question I
just think it's wrong
[Music]
okay good that you know bring that right
into the midterms it could not have
picked a better time for this
conversation uh and and for the
president United States to come out and
say he's not just
you know coming out in favor of
transitioning kids we already know he's
in favor of that he's saying states
don't have the right to regulate it they
actually don't have the right to you
don't have the right to legally protect
your own kids according to Joe Biden
and we are specifically talking about
gender surgeries for minors here
now that isn't said in the clip
instead it's just said well there are
some states who are trying to make these
procedures illegal yeah every state
where that is happening every single
state it is specifically focused on
minors there is no state that is
currently trying to make these kinds of
procedures illegal for everyone all of
the current laws that are on the books
or that are or that or that are being
proposed right now on their way to being
on the books are focused on kids so what
he's what the president United States is
saying there is that states do not have
the rights
to legally prevent doctors from
mutilating and castrating kids
and as I said if the if the Democrats
want to bring that
argument into the midterms I say
fantastic let them do it
there was a longer conversation between
uh
the guy and Woman face and Biden and
let's see a little bit more of that
and it it feels like Republicans have
turned trans and non-binary people into
this thing to blame society's downfall
on in some ways and this narrative is
not only dangerous to our mental health
but also our physical safety and
particularly trans women of color are
being murdered at an alarming rate more
than any other group of people thank you
how can Democratic leaders be more
effective in advocating for us trans
people and our families and our lives
and our opportunities
I'm not being facetious when I say this
being seen with people like you
know I mean it I genuinely mean it
people fear what they don't know
they fear what they don't know
and when people realize individuals
realize oh
this is what they're telling me to be
frightened up this is the problem this
is I mean people change their minds
people are just don't know enough to
know
and it's not because of intellectual
incapability it's just lack of exposure
and and I think that it's really
important that we continue to speak out
about the basic fundamental rights of
all human beings and the idea the idea
that was going on you know
in some states I won't get to know the
politics of it but in some states it's
just it's outrageous and I think it's
immoral
the trans part's not immoral
what they're trying to do to trans
persons is immoral
it's outrageous it's immoral to not
castrate kids Biden says first you know
they keep carrying on with this nonsense
uh so you know I have to continue
reminding you that it is nonsense the
stuff about the trans murder rate how
trans people are murdered more than
anyone else an alarming rate there's an
epidemic of anti-trans murders all of
that is it's a flat out lie they're
making it up all they do is make stuff
up and what they do is they report the
total number of trans people who were
supposedly murdered the total number all
of them every single murder and they
insinuate or outright claim that they
were all killed every single one of them
in anti-trans hate crimes so according
to them according to the left no trans
person is ever killed except as a hate
crime if it weren't for hate crimes
trans people would never be killed there
would be a murder rate of zero if not
for hate crimes when in reality when you
look at the data you see that
anti-transate crimes are extremely rare
okay almost I mean almost none of these
and of these uh murders are even
tangentially linked to hate crimes in
reality
um trans people for the most part are
murdered for the same reason everybody
else is domestic disputes drug related
prostitution
so if the trans murder rate is higher
than average it's because they engage in
high risk activities more than average
prostitution drug activity
and they do engage in those high risk
high-risk activities more than average
um and yet as it turns out even though
they engage in these high-risk
activities more than average the trans
murder rate is lower than the national
average a lot lower it's like three
times lower than the national average
so there were last year about 45 trans
people killed 45 total the entire year
in the whole country that's out of a
population of about 1.6 million people
who identify as trans according to most
recent estimates and that number of
course is going up uh very very fast
especially among young people
so 45 out of 1.6 million puts the murder
rate at
.002 percent
that's the epidemic .002 for the general
population it's point zero zero six
percent that's three times higher
also by the way if trans people were
really terrified for their lives they
wouldn't be act like
when you see Dylan Mulvaney do you see
someone who's Who's acting like like uh
he's terrified for his life
like there's just uh their their
anti-trans murderers waiting around
every corner is that how he's carrying
on
as for the rest of it uh that was just
babbling and coherent gibberish from
Biden as per usual he says people don't
know enough to know what does that mean
people don't know enough to know
I have no idea what that means I mean I
don't know enough to know what the hell
he's talking about
I'll say that
and he blames it on ignorance and he
says that people people just don't
understand they don't they don't know
they don't okay well we're asking
questions so if we're ignorant answer
the damn questions
it's like we're asking you to explain
your positions we're trying we're asking
you what the hell you're talking about
we're asking you that
And yet when you add we ask you scream
in our face with a bullhorn and say that
we're uh terrorists
there was more than happened there I
also wanted to play this briefly Biden
also demonstrated that uh and he went on
he talked to other people about other
issues embarrassing himself every single
time he also demonstrated that he
doesn't he doesn't understand his own
student loan bailout plan listen to this
secondly if you don't have one of those
loans you just get 10 000 written off
it's passed I got it passed by a voter
too
okay so we taught me the student loan
Bala plan he said it's it's passed by a
vote of two
who what
what do you think happened Gramps what
do you what are you remembering because
that was not
that that's you you just you did that on
your own that was a that was by
executive Fiat there was no legislation
passed for that you just did that
passed by a vote of two
what is he even talking about who who
are the two people
now that raises a lot of questions about
who's actually running the show over
there at the White House he also said
that he wants to force taxpayers to pay
for abortions or uh or reimburse for
abortions
do you support a federal fund for
individuals like myself who need to take
time off work obtain Child Care the
answer is absolutely but guess what we
need the same votes we need to overrule
that to reinstate the uh the decision
that was struck down by the court
I mean I do support that and I've urged
publicly urged companies to do that
I've urged them publicly as president
United States saying this is what you
should be doing I urge you to do it
foreign
yet another argument that the Democrats
can bring into the midterms so if you're
keeping track
what they're what they're proposing here
is uh forcing all taxpayers to reimburse
women who kill their babies
and uh also castrating and mutilating
kids so those are the two you know those
are the two um
there's more to their platform
but those are two major prongs of their
campaign of their platform
again it's just it's up to normal people
to look at that and say is that is that
the kind of country
you want to live in is that what you
believe in
all right moving on to other topics
briefly
that's just from the daily wire report
from yesterday it says U.S military
forces have deployed one of the nation's
most elite groups of Airborne Division
soldiers to Europe for the first time
since World War II vowing to fight
alongside Ukrainian troops in the war
against Russia according to a report CBS
News reported Friday at the U.S army is
101st
Airborne Division a group trained to
deploy anywhere in the world and and uh
fight within hours deployed
approximately four seven thousand forty
seven hundred soldiers from Fort
Campbell Kentucky to Romania where
soldiers stand ready to reinforce NATO's
Eastern flank on a moment's notice
the division's deputy Commander
Brigadier General John lubis told the
outlet were ready to defend every inch
of NATO's soil
well I want no part of this none at all
and you know the thing is they've been
telling us that there wouldn't be boots
on the ground only weapons and money no
just setting weapons of money and if you
believe that then there's really no hope
for you because it was always destined
to go this way it always is anytime the
federal government does anything
um first of all when they say that it's
temporary it never is and when they say
well we're only going to go this far and
no further it never is that's never true
either
and yet through this whole Ukraine
Affair this entire time months and
months now
still nobody has been able to explain
why Americans have any interest in this
conflict why it serves the interests of
Americans
to get involved at all
to defend Ukraine nobody's been able to
explain that
that's because they aren't trying to
explain it because that's not the
language that the globalists speak they
don't care about American interests they
care about their own interests the
interests of political leads defense
contractors military industrial complex
that's what they care about
they didn't even try they don't that's
my point they don't even try to couch
their arguments in terms of well this
this suits American interests for that
this reason like they can't even speak
that way
as for Americans
um
actual Americans like you and me we're
not served at all by getting involved or
ramping up our involvement rather in
Ukraine
there is no reason really
why you should be forced to care
about this fight whether Russia Ukraine
wins
there there are a great many violent
conflicts happening all over the globe
all the time
every day
and it's unfortunate
I wish that none of them were happening
I wish that there were no violent
conflicts I wish that all the violence
in this country wasn't happening but it
is
as far as the violent conflicts all
across the globe every day most of them
have nothing to do with us
and frankly shouldn't matter to us all
that much
this is one of those
and the response is always oh you're
pro-russia no I'm pro-america you dummy
I don't care about Russia I'm not
sitting around care but that's that's
not my country I'll let Russia worry
about Russia
and I'm also not sitting around caring
that much about Ukraine I'll let Ukraine
handle Ukraine
I wish the people the best
um I feel compassion in general for
people
that's why I say all the violent
conflicts happening all over the globe
I'm I I feel bad about the fact that
they're happening I don't I don't like
it
and when you tell me about one
particular incident or something that a
tragedy somewhere or whatever violent
conflict and I hear about it and I think
well that's that's a terrible thing
that's really terrible
but that's all I can say about it
there's nothing else to be said
the Fate
of other nations as political entities
is not my concern
it's their concern so let them work it
out why is this so hard
why is this a difficult concept to
understand
it really isn't
it or it shouldn't be
all right we also have uh well I gotta
mention this before we get to the
comment section because it's
just wonderful this is for the New York
Post it says a new book by Lefty
Democrat uh representative Corey Bush
debuted with a face plant this month
selling
729 copies in its first week according
to Industry tracker NPD book stand
uh the Forerunner a story of pain and
perseverance in America was released by
uh Knopf on October 4th the publisher
paid Bush an anti-police socialist who
stoked blmris in 2020 in advance of at
least fifty thousand dollars according
to Bush's Financial disclosure things
only went downhill from there with uh
NDP reporting just 288 books sold in its
second week
wow that it I almost feel bad
this is another tragedy I almost feel
bad about actually my compassion does
not extend far enough to really feel bad
about it but uh the book is billed as a
political Memoir which delves into
Bush's history as a minimum wage worker
Survivor of sexual violence and black
lives matter activist
industry insiders called the book launch
mediocre which which is big
really generous and said that the
publisher was unlikely to recoup their
investment yeah I would say so
the public yawn comes despite an intense
marketing Blitz which included fawning
reviews from friendly Outlets like New
York Magazine and Forbes women
the book received glowing testimonials
from Whoopi Goldberg Margaret Hoover and
Joy Reed Bush even plugged the Memoir on
The View and The Daily Show on the day
of its release
so you have to understand just what a
catastrophic
failure this is and it's very
reminiscent of um there was the book
about uh Dr Jill Biden
Dr Jill Biden that came out a few months
ago and we had fun talking about what a
I forget what the exact numbers were on
that but it was just a terrible nobody
bought the book nobody cared and that's
certainly the case here also keep in
mind 729 copies sold
a certain portion of those are going to
be bulk purchases uh organized by the
publisher or by people you know or by
Corey Bush's campaign or whatever
through surrogates so there's gonna be
some bulk purchases they do it's really
probably that's all of the books I don't
think any
actual real person went out and bought
this book or went to Amazon about
because why would they
and this is in spite of
the massive amount of publicity this is
the we talk about the advantages they
have on the left
and it's important to always highlight
those advantages not because we're
whining about them but because it makes
their failures all the more humiliating
for them
so this is the you can Cory Bush puts a
book out she has her pick of the litter
she can go on any show she wants to she
can get the book out in front of
millions of people all at once she can
do prime time she can do daytime TV she
can do all of that and she did
and still nobody bought it
and I I just have to point out that 729
copies
that is
fewer copies than Johnny The Walrus sold
in like the first hour of its release
and that's in spite of the fact
that of course because
I'm a conservative and I am myself
I don't get to appear on all these shows
I did Tucker Carlson which is a big
boost
that was it as far as big National shows
go that was it I really wanted to go on
The View we tried to make that happen
and it just it didn't
so 729 you know more than that an hour
and she does that in a week just a
horrific embarrassment for her
but again it shows keep so so we've got
Corey Bush selling no copies of her book
um and this is in the same around the
same time frame that AOC is doing her uh
Town Hall meetings and no one's showing
up to them and the few people who are
showing up are only are only there to
scream at her
so she got the sparsely attended
Town Halls books not selling anything
these are supposed to be this the new
stars of the Democrat Party this is the
squad we're talking about okay
Squad that's supposed to be the The
Beatles of the Democrat Party and nobody
cares about these people
nobody actually cares
this is all astro turf this is all uh
contrived
there are these political Sensations
entirely contrived by the media
and it's just uh
fantastic let's get to the comment
sections
[Music]
all right the Big E says there's
something about the way Matt uses the
term weirdo that carries so much more
weight than I feel it should if some
random person on the street called me a
weirdo I would never give it a second
thought but if Matt ever called me a
weirdo it would Pierce me to my very
soul
well I don't know why but I
I'm I'm very flattered by that I take
that as a high compliment
not exactly sure what it means
but I appreciate it
Sir Lionel says every single time I look
past Matt at the background I see
something new and absolutely bizarre but
we like to keep you guessing although
I'm not sure we have anything bizarre in
the background though well it's you know
we're going we're on the road it's hard
to bring the bizarre items with you but
uh you can see at least the walrus and
Johnny The Walrus back there nothing
bizarre about that Holly says uh every
time you win an argument the
relationship loses Dr Phil
she's quoting Dr Phil uh not talking to
him every time you win an argument the
relationship loses every time you win an
argument relationship uh I don't know if
I agree with that
as someone who enjoys winning arguments
I I cannot
line up behind the idea that it's bad to
win because if you win it means that so
here's here's the way all here's the way
all Parsons
in the context of a of a marriage
if if you're
having a discussion or an argument and
the only thing you care about is winning
if that's the only thing that matters to
you then the relationship loses
yeah if that's if that becomes the
objective in the argument which which is
what happens sometimes in marriages it
does happen and that's when you know
when all it is about winning you're just
trying to win this argument uh and then
you start you know you start bringing up
things that are irrelevant you just
start like you start throwing anything
you can against the wall uh just so you
can you know just so you can win
uh when you do that then yeah the
relationship loses but
if you're having an argument
or a heated discussion in a marriage
and you raise points
and then the other party concerned
realizes that the points you're raising
are correct and says so then it's hard
for me to see how the relationship loses
that is uh that is that is reunification
that was you were divided and you
reunified around the idea
that I am right
which it's hard for me to see
not that I've ever really had that
experience in my marriage but I'm just
saying if it were to happen I wouldn't
consider it a loss at all
uh M Lenny says Matt you probably
noticed that there's a tweet of yours
circulating from 2016 where you say that
yeah what else is new well you say that
the difference between Islam and
Christianity is that Christianity is
true
I've noticed a lot of Muslim accounts
reacting to this and seeming to be very
angry slash disappointed but I'm not
sure how that comment could be
controversial or why they're digging it
up all these years later yeah I did
notice that because I started getting
notifications from people uh trying to
dunk on this tweet six years later
by the way you can't dunk on a tweet six
years later dunks have to come in the
first day or two I think you have about
a 48 dunk window you have a 48-hour dunk
window for tweets and after that point
the game is over and you just it's too
late to dunk in this particular tweet
yes I said that Christianity is true in
Islam isn't there was a context for that
comment I didn't just say it randomly
there was context related to the news
cycle at the time that would have made
sense to people six years ago but this
is one of the cheapest and lamest things
people do on the internet where they
pull something completely out of the
conversational context years later and
they react to it as if it was blurted
out entirely at random
so it's just a lame thing but of course
in this case even if I did say it at
random it makes absolutely zero sense to
be offended by it what exactly are you
offended by of course I think
Christianity is true I'm Christian every
Christian believes that Christianity is
true or else they wouldn't be Christian
now there might be people who call
themselves Christian and don't believe
that Christianity is true but they're
not really Christian
and if I think the Christianity is true
then obviously I think that every other
religion is not true what else would I
think did people imagine that I'm a
Christian who actually secretly thinks
that Islam is true so what is the issue
here it's just completely absurd now
does that mean that there are no
redeeming qualities to other religions
like for example Islam or to other world
religions no I think that many religions
at least
at least the ancient ones anyway
um many of them are you know can be
quite beautiful and are are interesting
and have wisdom they contain wisdom
um
I also know that if somebody isn't
adherent to an old religion and is
serious about their faith
I will very often have much more in
common with them than I will with a
secular leftist
um
so I think all of that but I believe
that Christianity has the fullness of
Truth while other religions do not again
if I didn't believe that I wouldn't be a
Christian
as to why this is coming up now as far
as I can tell and I didn't do much
investigating but as far as I could tell
some seemingly large or prominent
accounts from the Arab speaking World
dug the Tweet up and have been passing
it around
and um and the reason they did that is
that my film what is a woman has been
quite popular among uh Muslims both in
this country and internationally
it's been a big hit you know in in that
community in their culture
which I think is great
and I've said many times I'm willing to
join forces with anyone on this issue
um the issue of defeating gender
ideology I would join forces with a
pro-abortion feminist on this issue
so of course I would join forces with a
devout Muslim but of course I would
don't even have to think about that
and I truly believe that a coalition an
alliance of devout Christians and devout
Muslims and devout people of all faiths
fighting back against this cultural
decay
could be extremely formidable
but there are apparently some as I said
muslim influencers I guess who are who
aren't interested in such an alliance
and so they went digging for stuff to
discredit me in that community and what
they found is that shocker I believe in
my own religion and not theirs
and now a very similar thing happened
with the feminists in the UK
who you know back in June were debating
whether to consider me an ally in the
gender ideology fight until a few of
them went digging and in their case they
didn't have to dig very far to find
opinions that I hold which they consider
to be abhorrent and uh and then they
successfully derailed any opportunity
for a let's say working relationship on
this issue it's like it seemed like we
were on the cusp maybe of yeah we can
work together on this and there were
some prominent feminists especially in
the UK who were saying there's no reason
we can't work together on this but then
other feminists who who you know are
opposed to the trans stuff they don't
want to do that so they went looking
through they said well here he said this
and this and this look at this he's no
friend of ours
and in that case they successfully
ruined any chance of uh of us working
together on that
there are always people who who want to
do that they're always people who just
they don't want to win and if they see a
strong Alliance forming and they see
momentum growing they just instinctively
do what they can to sabotage it I'm not
talking about people on the left doing
this I mean obviously they do
but I mean people who agree
on the issue
but just don't they don't want to win or
at least they don't want to win like
this
and there's they're always people it
doesn't matter what community you're
talking about it's always people doing
that
conservatives in general are notorious
for this absolutely notorious and as
someone who who wants to actually get
things done wants to get points on the
freaking board for a change
it frustrates me to no end
when anyone does this and as I said
conservatives but in this country I do
it all the time we get close we're
getting some momentum we're getting
close to being there we're forming
alliances and they go well we can't we
can't work with them or them or then we
can't do this we can't do that we should
be doing this differently
okay good job you just uh
you just throw a wrench into the works
but you have so so what what's your plan
for doing it better you don't have a
plan you have nothing
so I hope that doesn't work in this case
well as I talked about last week the
merch overlords have used my likeness to
pedalate Matt Walsh Halloween costume
the costume is nearly sold out only a
few more of you still have the chance to
identify as me this Halloween against my
best wishes and uh I think the better
judgment of everybody here that being
said if you happen to wear the costume
this week or next be sure to post a
picture on social media using what is a
costume and don't forget to tag me as
well you don't have to attack me I don't
want to see it you might even get a
repost or end up on the show
sure head over to dailywire.com shop for
your last chance to dress up as an
argumentative bastard this Halloween and
be sure to pick up a few more pieces of
merch while you're at it so whoever
wrote this copy just called me a bastard
this is this is what happens on the show
just people write copy insulting me to
my face and I read it
also we launched Jeremy's razors just a
few months ago we're already we've
already taken millions of dollars away
from woke razor companies that hate you
and use that money to better support
your values but time has come for
Jeremy's razors to look Inward and
conduct a totally legit not at all
Hollow or contrived Dei audit of
ourselves so here it is are Jeremy's
razors diverse no the razors are great
we don't need to make different ones our
Jeremy's razor is Equitable yeah well
yes when you buy a Founder's kit Equity
is transferred away from your pocket and
into Jeremy's right Jeremy's and lastly
are Jeremy's razors inclusive
of course they are because they include
blades so there you have it Jeremy's
razors is now Dei self-accredited and
still the only Razer brand who actually
upholds virtue instead of signaling it
and if you haven't already done so get
your shave kit today at
jammiesraisers.com and in case you
missed it Ben Shapiro released a brand
new episode of his Sunday special this
weekend it features a very special guest
the president of Brazil you can watch
the episode on daily wire Plus or listen
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcast that is literally
everything happening at the daily wire
right now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
there is no way to begin today's daily
cancellation except to dive right into
it uh here's the Yahoo news report it
says comedian Jordan gray strip naked on
Channel 4 as part of the revived special
episode of Friday Night Live the 80s
comedy series returned for a one-off
episode on Friday uh on Friday 21st of
October as part of the Channel's 40th
anniversary celebrations
Ben Elton was back at the helm whoever
that is along with former Friday Night
Live cast members Enfield brand and
Julian Clary the comic who is trans
performed a rendition of the song Better
Than You from her critically acclaimed
Edinburgh Fringe show is it a bird at
the end of the song gray who completed
competed on The Voice in 2016 shouted
out the best thing about live TV is I
can do stupid stuff like this after
improvising on the keyboard she then ran
across the stage and stripped completely
naked to Applause and cheers from the
audience before returning to the
keyboard and playing it with her penis
with her penis
I mean that whole sentence
she played the piano with her penis
imagine someone like from 15 years ago
come arriving here in a time machine and
the first sentence they read is that
now there's a video that goes along with
this story but I will spare you such
Horrors
um you need not suffer as I have
suffered in fact I became aware of this
story as I was scrolling down my Twitter
feed on Saturday and the video
um popped up and started playing
assaulting my eyeballs and my soul
without my consent
this is by the way one of the many
reasons you should keep your kids off of
social media if you aren't already and
perhaps keep yourself off of it also uh
social media
subjects us to lots of imagery that we
do not want to see and certainly did not
have in mind when we opened the app and
started scrolling just a constant stream
of ugliness and filth and insanity and
many other kinds of awful depressing
things thanks the internet we have all
seen things
that no human being should ever have to
see traumas that the human mind was not
made to withstand burdens it was not
intended to carry and this story
provides a good example of that sort of
thing in fact forget about social media
this degenerate Predator did this on
live television with children in
physical attendance in the auditorium
and also watching on TV
he exposed himself to kids and to plenty
of other people who did not consent to
it he is a predatory creep who should be
in prison
but instead he is of course being
celebrated by the left the independent
uh the outlet the independent went so
far as to call the the indecent exposure
episode bold hilarious and get this
life-changing it was life-changing to
see this guy
um playing the piano with his penis many
other Leftovers on social media echoed
the sentiment extolling the grotesque
repulsive site with the sorts of glowing
adjectives usually reserved for
something like the Sistine Chapel
vastly overcompensating in their efforts
to pretend that they weren't as grossed
out as the rest of us were
which I can guarantee you most of them
in fact work
I think this all reveals two things
well there was something else that was
revealed too but we aren't going to
discuss that in any detail as for the
other two
first of all if it wasn't already clear
to you it should now hopefully be
apparent that the days of leave us alone
and stay out of our private lives are
over and they've been over for a long
long time in fact those days never
really existed they never started
left-wing LGBT activists pretended they
wanted us out of their bedrooms
but we were never in their bedrooms and
we never requested access to their
bedrooms every time they said get it out
of our bedrooms you know we always said
but no don't worry I'm not I'm not
coming in there don't have to worry
about that
what they really wanted and have now
succeeded in doing
is to turn the whole world into their
bedroom
to act out their sexual fantasies in
full view of the public
more than that and this is all the more
the case for Trans activists
specifically
they want us to participate in their
sexual fantasies this is the demand of
the trans activist he wants you to not
only he wants to not only to expose you
to his fantasies and fetishes but he
demands that you play a role whether you
like it or not
so here we have a trans person with an
exhibitionist fetish and everyone
watching channel 4 on Friday night and
many other Millions more who happen to
be scrolling through social media the
following day are forced to be actively
involved
just by being Witnesses by being
spectators
sexual perversion and rampant out of
control narcissism that is trans
activism in a nutshell if you'll pardon
the expression second point
I've always said that male privilege at
least in modern Western societies is a
myth
but I should update or amend that claim
because male privilege is a myth for
most men however men who identify as
women enjoy the most privilege of all in
other words the only men who have male
privilege are the men who identify as
female
now a woman who stripped her clothes
entirely off on live television would be
harshly criticized for it rightly so
and that's true even in our current age
when women who make sexual objects of
themselves are celebrated and glorified
but there are still limits however
arbitrary those limits might be a woman
who did something similar
would have her you know she'd have her
Defenders certainly no doubt but she
would have a great many critics too
and that's even more the case for
so-called quote-unquote cisgender men
otherwise known as just men if this was
if this was some dude who identified as
a dude and fully exposed himself on
television
he would be seen straightforwardly as a
predator a Harvey Weinstein type
he would be after all exposing himself
to an audience without that audience's
consent
now considering what counts as sexual
harassment these days a guy pulling his
penis out on stage and whipping it
around would without question be found
guilty of it
you could be accused of crossing the
sexual harassment line if you pay a
woman a compliment in a way that she
finds creepy or awkward or whatever so
exposing your genitals to thousands of
women all at once without their consent
would obviously obliterate that line
wherever the line is drawn
so if this was a man who identifies as a
man he would have then no Defenders
anywhere nobody would be offending
but the man
who is who is still a man and identifies
as a woman
for him it's only this this act of
sexual harassment becomes bold beautiful
life-changing
so male privilege yeah definitely that
exists with a caveat
the male with privilege is the male who
denies that he is one
and the privilege he has given is not
one that any decent human being would
want because he has the privilege of
being a narcissistic predatory
self-obsessed degenerate
and we're all meant to applaud the very
behavior that we rightly scorn when
exhibited by literally anybody else
now many people have gone along with
these rules for far too long and that's
how we've gotten to the point where a
guy who calls himself a woman would feel
entitled to take his penis out on live
television
if this is not a message to the tolerant
masses that they've
been far too tolerant and need to start
being a lot more intolerant then I don't
know if they'll ever get the message if
they don't get it now
I can only hope that this is enough
and I can say to this guy
who should be on a sex offender registry
right now
and would be if you didn't have the
trans your way out of jail free card I
could say to him
you are canceled
and that'll do it for us today as we
move over to the members block of the
show hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]